see
[Music]
sonia
today marks an important day for
innovation in europe as we reach a
crucial milestone for the setting up of
the eu unified unitary patent system
with the provisional application of the
agreement on the unified patent court a
new era begins for european companies
and smes as patents are the most potent
intellectual property tool with a
particular strategic importance in our
knowledge-based economy
the long-awaited unitary patent will
enable simple and affordable patent
protection in europe with a single
procedure for the registration of
patents and centralized litigation
it will significantly reduce the costs
of patent protection to the benefits of
companies in particular smes
for instance a unitary patent covering a
territory of potentially up to 25 member
states will cost less than 5 000 euro
in renewal fees over 10 years instead of
the current amount of around 29 000
euros
more information is available in the
daily news published today and also a
statement by commissioner
thank you
merci beaucoup
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
any questions on foreign affairs for us
today
yes please
hello peter irena summer interface
can you please tell us if you already
have a confirmation that state secretary
lincoln
will come and will participate in the
monday foreign affairs council thank you
i can confirm that high representative
borel invited uh secretary of state
lincoln to participate in uh the
discussions of the foreign ministers
within the framework of the regular fac
which is foreign first council which is
planned for the upcoming
monday for the next monday
and the issues on the agenda of the
ministers where secretary blinken was
invited to participate include obviously
the the current discussions and
international efforts by partners to
deal with the issues related to russian
proposals or rather to russian attempts
to redefine the european security
architecture and it takes place in the
framework of the ongoing close
cooperation and discussions both within
the european union and between the
european union and its partners such as
united states nato canada because
certainly hrvp is meeting the canadian
foreign minister and also within the
framework of our contacts with the oec
which is the primarily international
platform that is supposed to deal with
the security questions in europe
is he coming well i mean
the
invitation was sent out was conveyed by
the hrvp and i think it's up to the
invitee to confirm his participation
thank you
any other questions
on this um on this issue
if not perhaps uh let me simply also
point you to uh the text of the speech
which the president
has made in the context of the
davos economic forum um this morning
and which we are of course making
available where she of course also
mentions
the situation
related to
ukraine and in which she reiterated once
again that if the situation deteriorates
if there are attacks on the territorial
integrity of ukraine will respond with
massive economic and financial sanctions
right
henry is your question on foreign
affairs
hello yes it is go ahead
go ahead yeah peter can i ask you
directly does the european uh
commission's the eeas support president
emmanuel macron's proposal
for the eu to come up with its own
idea for european security and present
that to russia
outside of the ongoing negotiations
involving the us thank you
thank you what we are focused right now
um are the very intense contacts and
coordination as i said both within the
european union there was a meeting
informal meeting of foreign ministers
and defense ministers of the eu last
week in brest in france there will be
fac discussions regular discussions by
the foreign ministers of eu member
states on monday this issue is on the
agenda the issue of russia how to
approach russia how to deal with the
challenges posed by russia the efforts
are continuing the eas works together
closely with and for the member states
so this is an overall joint effort in
order to formulate use position which
has been already um stated many times uh
within the framework of the ongoing
contacts and and coordination both
within the eu and between the eu and the
partners transatlantic partners such as
us canada nato but also with the oec
okay thank you very much
any last question for peter before i
release him
it is not the case thank you very much
so we close the foreign affairs chapter
for uh today and yes
i take your question
i think it's not yes it's the
tv pulse that it's a question for
christian
i would like um to know uh if you could
confirm officially that the call for
payments regarding the disciplinary
chamber
has been sent to poland yesterday for
which amount and what deadline is
expected and does it mean that the
letter received from warsaw last week
didn't persuade the commission to not
sell to not send this call for payments
because in the letter the polish
authorities
asked to not do it
and they were persuading that the
changes will happen but according to
polish legislation and constitution they
just need time for it thank you
okay now it works
okay good afternoon thank you derota for
your question
yes indeed after analyzing the reply uh
from poland to a letter from 22 december
the european commission has concluded
that poland failed to provide evidence
that it complies with the order issued
by the court of justice on the 14th of
july last year
the measures so far adopted by the
polish authorities had already been
brought to the attention of the vice
president of the court
in the context of the court proceedings
and deemed as insufficient
the european commission has therefore
sent the first call for payments
yesterday
and requested poland to pay the
penalties covering the period from free
november
2021 to 10 january 2022 included
following the first call the commission
will be sending regular calls for
payments on a monthly
basis
it of course remains for poland to
urgently comply with the court's order
of 14th july
um on your on your
other or one of your questions i think i
already replied to most of them uh but
on the deadlines what i can still
clarify is that uh if
um
that the call for payment requests um
is due within for the payment
uh in response to the request is due
within 45 days
from the receipt of the call for payment
all right any other questions on this
cal
we are coming
there are two cases one about the coal
mine and one about the judiciary system
can you please tell us when at the
earliest the commission could start
deducting
some amount of fines from eu transfers
to poland
and what happens if the czech republic
and poland find an agreement on the coal
mine and the czech republic withdraws
its complaint
this is a
it's the same issue but a different
issue it's not christian um so are there
any other questions related to this
particular um
fine related to the disciplinary chamber
that is not the case so now we can move
to balash on the more general questions
related to compensation
compensation efforts
which
which relate now to the two of
mine case
balash
good afternoon indeed so i will switch
to the other case that we have ongoing
at the moment
on that front what i can repeat is that
we have sent uh three first calls
for payment until now so all these three
calls considering different time periods
going from the 20th of uh september um
until the
18th of december now the very first of
these uh verse was sent on the 10th of
november you might recall and it
concerns the time period going from the
20th of september until the 19th of
october now on that front um we have
seen the expiry of a deadline of 45 days
plus 15
days
in the recent past which means that the
commission according to the applicable
legal procedures has to go a step
further and and proceed to the so-called
off setting um procedure which is uh uh
which is the very procedure on going at
at the moment now there was another
question on what happens if um it's an
it's a hypothetical uh question but if
eric allows i will give a generic answer
uh to that so um even if a solution is
found between the two member states that
you have made an allusion to
the payment the fine would still have to
be paid between
the 20th of
september which is the day when the
court imposed the fine and the day when
hypothetically
the members that we refer to withdraws
um the
case from the court of justice
okay
clear okay very good
i see no further questions on this
so i go back to alexander who had raised
his hands
in
interactio
previously alexander alexander
hi thank you very much for the question
um i have a question about the eu us
data equivalency negotiations
the the successor to privacy shield i
think it might be christian
might be johannes just wondering what
the state of play is
i'm asking the question because
kent walker
the chief lawyer for um
for google sent out a blog
yesterday night asking for
the talks to speed up because
he didn't say it but it's because
there's all sorts of dpa decisions that
are coming out that
are
a threat to google analytics and mac
shrems has been tweeting so i was hoping
for a reaction and a state of play thank
you
thanks alexander i don't know if
christian has any update to provide
question
well i can i can give you the state of
play where we stand of course
on the privacy
street negotiations the securing a new
arrangement
for safe transatlantic data flows is a
priority for us and for our us partners
the negotiations have intensified in the
past months there have been
discussions on technical level
and
also
regular contacts on political level
commissioner rangers has been 2ds
at the last
in
mid-december
uh meeting u.s secretary for commerce
junior raimondo
having said that of course only an
arrangement that is fully compliant with
the requirements set out by the european
court of justice can deliver the
stability and the legal certainty that
stakeholders expect on both sides of the
atlantic
therefore these negotiations take some
time given also the complexity of the
issues at hand and need to strike a
balance between privacy and national
security
thank you
any other questions for christian on
this
that is not the case any other questions
for us today
i would like to know if there's already
a confirmed
a date
for the college for the second part of
the delegated act on taxonomy and what
the state of all of the reactions of the
member states on this case thank you
thank you generic answer to uh to your
question on this as you know we never
communicate on the agenda of the college
until the end of the hebdo meeting that
takes place uh just um
while on the monday before before the
college meeting so i'm afraid you will
have to wait until um until i'm here and
announce the agenda of the of the of the
college and in that context work on
taxonomy is ongoing and for the moment
we have no further comment to make
follow-up
okay you can imagine that i'm not happy
with your answer but i would like it to
know nevertheless
uh
uh
the con the reactions of the member
states are confidential as well for sure
but we know already a lot of it because
they communicate in themselves but
nevertheless
can we expect that
it will might be
on the agenda
i won't i won't
ask
this year but but this month perhaps
as foreign
thank you
i believe that
what is absolutely crystal clear is that
the commission has uh um uh
full uh has no intention of postponing
this um in any way we are working hard
uh on the process as you know and
therefore we will come forward
with with the decisions on this uh as
as quickly as possible but i'm not going
to get into a game about dates because
as i say it's a point of principle we
only appoint we only announce commission
agendas after hebdo it's not my
prerogative to announce things before
that
anything else for us today
no then thank you very much and see you
tomorrow